[Music]
sucking wolves kill those website as
those hungry social media network tech
companies and advertisers pop up and
grab your personal info what you do on
your device is where you go heck what
pills you might take you hit back and
turn on privacy settings thinking you
stopped them but nope they pop up again
with new ways to get your info it's nice
that in the last few weeks Google and
Facebook have talked about new privacy
tools at their Developers Conference in
this is the next chapter but they still
put too much work on us and there are
too many loopholes we're probably never
gonna win it their game at least without
some better privacy laws default privacy
protection more transparency think of
each of these machines is a company
wanting to get your information for
advertising you've got Facebook over
here Google over here and lots of other
apps and companies that suck up your
information for advertising then think
of each of these moles as the different
ways they pop up and grab your data this
little guy here is in charge of watching
everything you do on the web this cute
one here he looks out for your phones
unique ad identifiers
it's like your own personal flag that
you unknowingly wave to the companies
that want to sell you stuff this loan he
hides in your downloaded apps this
little one he stalks your every move in
the real world via GPS and other
location data
so you get out your privacy settings
mallet to try and whack those moles
forever you jump from app to app menu to
menu and switch on protections but how
do they keep popping back up well take
these examples you can turn off location
tracking but then companies figure out
another way to track your location say
with your IP address or the turnoff
cookie tracking but they use
fingerprinting a technique where they
put together other info from your device
like what Wi-Fi or cellular networks
you're on or time zones to figure out
who you are using a special software
proxy tool my colleague mark Secada and
I tested 80 apps many of which Apple
promotes as apps we love in all but one
of them we found mobile ad trackers
sending data without any indication to
the user one of our findings meditation
apps are sucking up a lot of data
averaging six trackers each house then
you can limit web cookie tracking to a
degree the best thing you can do is use
a privacy focus browser like Firefox or
Safari if you use Chrome download the
EFS privacy badger extension which shows
you what trackers are being used and
lets you block them
with both Google and Facebook go through
their privacy check up tools on Facebook
specifically turn off everything under
ad settings on Google turn off the
location history tool which logs
everywhere you've been the best thing
you can do is limit tracking at the
operating system level on the iPhone
go to settings privacy advertising and
toggle on limit ad tracking make sure
you've turned off location tracking on
the apps that really don't need your
location on Android and iOS go into
settings and find that location setting
and disable access for the apps that
really don't need the info okay sure
I've made this all out to seem like a
game but at the end of the day our
dwindling privacy is anything but that
despite new promises about privacy and
giving us new controls the tech
companies have continued to put too much
of the privacy onus on us I'm like a
game of whack-a-mole I mean wacko
tracker it feels like it may never end
[Applause]
you
you